para mi adiós considerado por muchos el
mejor futbolista de la historia nació el
30 de octubre de 1960 en villa fiorito
provincia de buenos aires- debutó en
primera división jugando para argentinos
juniors a los 15 años en argentina
además de jugar en la paternal visión
los colores de boca juniors y new scholl
boys de rosario
el disparo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
de buenos aires- salto a europa y
desembarco en barcelona donde tuvo un
paso fugaz y con muy poca repercusión
con los blaugranas ganó la copa del rey
de 1983 agente también logró una liga
luego llegaría club que lo convertiría
en leyenda en nápoles con un modesto
equipo logró dos scudettos una copa
italiana y una copa de la uefa
maradona encarnó en italia aquello que
siempre representó la lucha de los menos
favorecidos contra los poderosos la
eterna pelea del sur pobre contra el
norte rico
su paso por europa culminar ya con una
triste imagen en el sevilla de españa
antes de volver al equipo de sus amores
del que siempre se declaró hincha boca
juniors
como entrenador dirigió a racing a las
world de emiratos árabes unidos- dorados
de sinaloa de méxico gimnasia esgrima de
la plata de argentina
con la selección argentina fue campeón
en 1979 del mundial sub-19 en japón pero
sería en méxico-86 donde su punto más
alto lo convirtió en leyenda sólo unos
años después de finalizar la guerra de
las malvinas hizo un gol con la mano y
marcó el mejor gol de la historia de los
mundiales todo eso contra el rival que
los había vencido en batalla inglaterra
luego de muchos años sin actividad llegó
el momento de dirigir a la selección
argentina su sueño entre 2008 y 2010
incluido el mundial de sudáfrica dirigió
24 partidos ganó 18 y perdió 6